One way of thinking about this is to talk in terms of differences. This chart
illustrates the differences between different states and the goal state. So, for
example, if the current state was this one then this red line illustrates
the difference from the goal state. So we should pick an operator that will
help reduce the difference between the current state and the goal state.
So the reduction between the difference with the current state and
the goal state is the end. The application of the operator is the means.
That's why it's called the means-ends analysis. At any given state,
I'm going to pick an operator that will help you deduce the difference between
the current state and the goal state. Note in a way this problem is similar to
the problem of part finding in robotics, where we have to design a robot that
could go from one point to another point in some navigation space.
>From my office to your office, for example, if all our offices were in the same
building. There too we would use the notion of distances between offices. Here
we using the notion of distance in a metaphorical sense, in a figurative sense,
not in a physical sense. So I'll sometimes use the word difference instead of
distance but it's the same idea. We are trying to deduce the distance or
the difference but in an abstract space. So going back to an example of going
from this initial state to this goal state. I can look at initial state and
see that there are three differences between the initial state and
the goal state. First, A is on table here, but A should be on B.
B is on table here, but B should be on C. And third, C is on top of A here,
the C should be on top, on table there. So three differences. Here the number of
operations are available to us. Nine operations in particular. Let us do
a means-end analysis. We can apply an operator that would put C on table.
In which case the difference between the new state and the goal state will be
two. We could apply an operator that will put C on top of B,
in that case the difference between the current state and the goal state will
still be three. Or we can apply the operator putting B on top of C,
in which case the distance between the current state and
the goal state will be 2. Notice that the notion of reducing differences now
leads to two possible choices. One could go with this state or with this one.
Means-end analysis by itself does not help an AI agent decide between this
course of action and that course of action. This is something that we
will return to, both a little bit later in this lesson and even much more in
detail when we come to planning in this course. For now, let us resume that we
choose the top course of action just like they had done already there. So
this chart illustrates the pot taken from the initial state to the goal state.
And the important thing to notice here is that with each different move
the distance between the current state and the goal state is decreasing,
from three to two to one to zero. This is why means-end analysis comes up
with this path because at each time it reduces a difference